[Générique d'intro]
[LE HOBBIT - Director's cut]
*effets d'annonce*
[T'imagines si Bilbo était raciste...]
*machine à écrire*
[musique aventureuse nocturne]
- Allez...
- Non.
[musique aventureuse nocturne]
- Rhooo... ALLEZ...
- NON !
[musique aventureuse nocturne]
[désespéré] : - Ohlàlà...
- Bon, Bilbo, il faut vraiment que tu m'accompagnes.
*bruits nocturnes*
- C'est pas mes affaires, Gandalf.
- Mais tu comprends pas, ça va être une épopée incroyable
*bruits nocturnes*
*bouche pleine* - Non, non, non.
Tu pourras raconter ce récit épique à tes enfants...
*bruits nocturnes*
et on va se faire des meufs !
- J'ai une meilleure idée : à la place, on fait...
*bruits nocturnes*
Une tarte !
- Mais t'es dégueulasse !
*bruits nocturnes*
Smaug le dragon, il a été méchant avec les nains !
- Ça va, il s'est excusé depuis...
*bruits nocturnes*
- Mais il leur a volé leur trésor !
[exaspéré] : - Oh arrête...
*bruits nocturnes*
les nains, aussi...
[l'imitant] : - Quoi "les nains aussi"... ?
*bruits nocturnes*
- Ben les nains, quoi !
- Ben QUOI "les nains, quoi" ?
*bruits nocturnes*
[...]
- Ben, ils ont tout le mithril !
*bruits nocturnes*
[désolé] - Oh, mais non-...
[excité] : - Franchement, les nains, ils n'ont pas tout le mithril ?
*bruits nocturnes*
[désolé] : - Mais tu fais des amalgames, là...
- Excusez-moi, parce que je vous écoute depuis tout à l'heure,
*bruits nocturnes*
et, bon, ben, je suis outré,
mais euh... On a besoin de vous,
*bruits nocturnes*
pour récupérer le trésor, donc si vous êtes prêt à partager,
vous pouvez venir avec nous.
*bruits nocturnes*
- D'accord.
[...]
*bruits nocturnes*
Je prends 50%.
- 20.
*bruits nocturnes*
- 40.
- 22.
*bruits nocturnes*
- 30, et des chaussettes en mithril.
- 25, et une part de tarte.
*bruits nocturnes*
- Quel goût ?
- Rhubarbe.
*bruits nocturnes*
[...]
- Ok.
*bruits nocturnes*
[...]
Putain, vous êtes fort en négociation, hein.
*bruits nocturnes*
En même temps, vous êtes nain.
[...]
*bruits nocturnes*
- Bon allez, en route !
- Attendez, attendez ! Avant de partir, je voudrais vous demander un truc.
*bruits nocturnes*
- Quoi ?
[...]
*bruits nocturnes*
- Je veux faire du "stand-up".
- Oh, fuyez, pauvre fou !
*bruits nocturnes*
- Quoi ?
- Ça marchera jamais, tout le monde veut faire du "stand-up".
*bruits nocturnes*
- Ben quoi, il peut peut-être m'aider, lui ?
- Mais en quoi je peux vous aider ?
*bruits nocturnes*
- Ben vous êtes nain !
- Et alors ?
*bruits nocturnes*
[...]
- B'alors quoi, vous avez des connexions dans le show-biz, non ?
*bruits nocturnes*
[...]
- Là, ça devient très gênant par contre.
*bruits nocturnes*
- Vraiment, je suis désolé, excusez-le...
- Juste un passage, un seul passage, un seul,
*bruits nocturnes*
et après c'est bon, je vous laisse tranquille.
[...]
*applaudissements*
[Générique *Mordor Comedy Club*]
*rires* *applaudissements*
J'me retourne, j'fais : Mais ! Regarde où tu vas !
Et là, la licorne me fait :
"Ah pardon, 'excuse-moi, j'regardais pas".
*rires*
Merci, c'tout pour moi. C'était Bilbo.
*cris* *applaudissements*
- Excellent, excellent...
J'adore ce mec, il vient de la Comté.
*applaudissements*
- Hein, c'était bien ?
- Ouais, c'était pas mal, hein.
Sutout la petite vanne sur les orcs.
- Ah, cool !
- Et puis bonne énergie, hein !
- Ah, merci, les gars, c'est sympa.
- Atchik-atchik-atchik ?
- URUK-HAI !
- Le prochain, mes elfes & mes elfes, c'est un fou.
Il n'est pas comme nous, les elfes.
Il a fait la première partie de Dumbo Magie,
je l'ai trouvé dans la forêt de la Dame Blanche
en train de sucer des racines :
DU BRUIT POUR BOMBUR !!!
*cris* *applaudissements*
Bonsoir ! Vous savez, nous, les nains,
on est souvent pris de haut.
*rires*
La semaine dernière, j'me promenais avec ma licorne - j'ai une licorne ;
et je croise un mec, et le mec il me dit :
"Dis donc, elle est pas un peu grosse pour toi, mon petit bonhomme ?"
*rires*
J'ai dit : "C'est marrant, ta femme m'a dit la même chose hier soir !"
[chuchoté] : - Attends, c'est vachement communautaire, quand même ?
- Ben ouais, je sais, mais y'a que ça qui marche, maintenant...
*cris* *rires*
[Générique de fin]
#Sous-titres : El Micà.